hey guys how are you we thank you
welcome where you guys from Kalamazoo
Michigan fine welcome to Nashville and
here to do your debt-free scream I
understand yes we are excellent how much
have you paid off we paid off a hundred
and four thousand dollars in about four
years I love it very cool and making
what kind of money during that four
years wait for my little under 100 - I
just touch over a hundred gotcha
okay right around the hundred thousand
mark what do you guys do for a living
I'm in sales I'm a veterinarian Oh fine
very good good for you guys so what kind
of debt was this it was all my student
loan debt that they're in student loan
debt
yeah oh cool so are you part-time or
full-time or part-time full-time all
right how long have you been out of
school for years it's almost 10 2006 we
had the loans deferred as long as we
could and then we went into forbearance
and then we got sick and tired and what
happened four years ago what caused you
to get after this we really got tired of
just constantly screwing up I mean we
won a single event when you share one
morning and you said that's it or one
night we were getting ready to have our
fourth child we don't check on his
secret life and every other time we had
one of our babies that was just preceded
by something not good happening we had a
jab last way to move across the country
and then the third time we're going to
really do it I was like we can't go the
same route again because it's such a
stressful time in your life and we just
sent ourselves up for failure and had to
overcome a lot of things in order to do
well and so once we started getting
ready to work on number three it was
like we got to you know do something
different I was gonna be exactly where
we were before okay so that the pressure
of the third child woke you up yeah yeah
okay that's cool that's good and then
what happened then we actually just
started getting really we thought we
were getting really intense but we spent
a year and we actually only paid off
like $10,000 and we're looking to stare
down the barrel 104 and we realized okay
it's still not going right we weren't
working your plan
we went to finally what the FPU after
about a year and that the last three
years are really kidding in the gear and
paint off the rest of it in the last
three years gotcha there so you so you
only did ten thousand the first year out
of the four years yeah yeah okay and
then you went to Financial Peace
University yeah what at your church or
just a local rebounded Church yeah well
you never went to church before okay and
so we found a church still go and opu
actually I mean it changed our lives in
the financial sense but it also changed
our lives in our connection with God and
and found us a church and a family there
and it's just changed everything that's
more important than that guys thank you
very cool so where do you go to church
we go to radiant church in Richland
Michigan cool very cool and that's right
next to Kalamazoo yesterday very neat
yeah I've been right through there a
couple times over the years yep and I'm
fine well congratulations you guys
wanted you transformation for your lives
all the way around Merry Christmas and
all that I think the thing that we're
most excited about is to raise our boys
to not have to go through the same
journey we have interested be raised in
a debt-free household they all know what
a budget is there's three five and seven
and no they all know one sale is exactly
well congratulations you guys right over
the four years three the first year was
$10,000 you got in there Financial Peace
University and you get in gear and then
you knock out the other 90,000 in three
years now that's starting to be really
impressive at that point making a
hundred because that's put you on beans
and rice rice and beans with three kids
yes without a doubt what was the hardest
part of this for y'all for me the
hardest part was just changing my
mindset and making the important things
more important and the less important
material things less important and
realizing that you know you don't have
to have those impulse purchases all the
time to make you a happy person what
would you what would you attribute that
change in mindset to what caused that
change in mindset because I agree with
you I think that's a good observation
yeah um well I mean why did you change
your mindset I mean what made you change
your mindset my children I what does
that mean finally had some
thing I mean not that together why I got
my wife looking beyond yourself looking
long-term a change your family trees
because I think a lot of times when
we're materialistic and we all are
sometimes it's more of a short-term
thing yeah thinking yeah its short-term
thinking and what we think is important
but when we change our mindset to quote
you it usually means that we started
thinking longer-term yes and kids is one
way of doing that and you know changing
your family tree having a different
legacy that changes you know all of that
is causes you to go it's just a car yeah
it's just it's just some shoes I mean
that's fine but it's like when you're
like in the short-term those shoes will
make me happy you know that exact kind
of a thing I think that's how we all
think yeah probably that's a good
insight thank you and what was your
hardest part Michael mechanically it was
it was looking at the last student loan
the last food loan was only it was like
fifty thousand dollars and we were
paying them off like one by one by one
you're going through much like fives and
tens and then when you get to that last
$50,000 one boom it slows down yeah yeah
because you're right a ureña check and
you eat a bonus and all of a sudden they
don't move
yeah and just gonna go on going and yeah
for us to to see that we had to rely
back on just you know what our end goal
was and kind of refocus on that because
that made it really tough we don't we
never really lost focus but we certainly
came close to it a couple times and we
had some tense budget meetings it's the
worst fight you had over a budget
recently not a hold on but recently
actually this trip was one of them
because I've been listening to you in
the car every single day and I got you
on the podcast now I can't wait to get
back to work so I got a bunch as podcast
stored up now
but I've been wanting to come down here
for four years and Amber's wanted to
come down too but then we were looking
at just the trying to budget for this
trip and we had to make a compromise
because amber wanted to stay in a night
which was kind of weird cuz I was when
we want to come down here and then she
want to say in action I eat the hotel
rate doubled we had a big long
discussion about that and wound up
compromising so we're what you do
but we're gonna stop at Mammoth Cave on
the way they let you sleep they're free
fun guys way to go very cool good good
real stuff I love it
alright and Connor and Eric and Noah are
around here okay we'll bring them in
here let's let's see them I listed me
down on the screen so we'll get them
included in the debt free screen because
if you come all the way from Kalamazoo
Michigan
have they been practicing yes especially
the five year olds the eric is the five
year old all right Eric I want to hear a
great debt free scream buddy on you you
have a reputation of being a great debt
free scream guys so happy counting on
you all right here we go hundred and
four thousand dollars paid off in four
years making a hundred thousand a year
Michael amber Connor Eric and Noah count
it down let's hear a debt free scream
three two one
good job guys good job well done well
done
you guys would be so rich so fast and be
able to do so much not only for
yourselves and for your family but for
others